someone must have pissed you off for you
to start your own third party andrew
like someone must someone must have said
something or done something you said you
know what
i just can't do this anymore you know
the problem isn't anything in terms of
personal interaction the problem is that
everyone is stuck and then even if
you're a successful politician within
let's say the democratic party you're
stuck you know
like your uh behavior is constrained
your policy positions are constrained
uh and uh you know you have a ton of
masters to serve and you know media
complex that that's going to be pushing
you in a particular direction
uh i'm a problem solver you know like i
i don't know if you all sense this like
i don't really care about like you know
my own political advancement but anyone
who's in that system all of a sudden
does care and you know the big thing
that people underestimate is that they
get surrounded by dozens of professional
political operatives who also have their
careers on the line you know it's like
hey we need you to do this and that
because
uh you know we need to get better jobs
ourselves or you know we need to be able
to go on to the next gig
um and that's one thing i appreciate
about the folks who worked on my
campaign is most of them were not
careerists in that way until we raised
we ran into raising 40 million dollars
so after we passed like you know 20 25
million the freaking consultants came
out of the woodwork uh all of a sudden
they weren't like hey like i'm here we
can make some money here now yeah yeah
yeah
we're here to help and this is the thing
that also you know as a business guy at
first i was like frankly like you know
we don't need these consultants like
where were they you know like six months
ago um but then when you're in a
position where you have to spend eight
million dollars on tv ads in iowa you do
hire the consultants because you're like
well hey i'm not gonna like start from
scratch like like yeah yeah at that
point then it's like well how do i do
this professionally but that's the smart
move to do i think you do need to bring
some people up it's like a company when
the company is doing a million two
million three million maybe you can
manage it when it starts doing 20 30 40
million you kind of need to start
bringing some of the c-suite executives
who know how to put systems
infrastructure you know protocols all
that stuff so that that's kind of makes
sense yeah but but the the point is that
like the the system is going to keep
producing certain kinds of uh candidates
and certain kinds of results and like to
me that's not going to solve the problem
andrew going back to it so
uh forward party how much momentum have
you had ever since you announced it it's
been tremendous because more and more
people are waking up to the reality that
the current two-party system is not
working and it's not going to deliver
what you want no matter what you want
it's not going to deliver unless what
you want is people to go crazy and get
more and more upset at each other if
that's what you want it's going to
deliver that because it's delivering
that in a hell of a way yeah it's going
to deliver that um so more and more
people go to fordparty.com every day
they sign up they volunteer
they donate and we have some really
exciting announcements coming up so it's
a good feeling because patrick you've
been a part of these growth stories you
know when you you have product market
fit and you feel like okay like we're
going to grow from here that's been the
feeling if you enjoyed this short clip
click over here to watch another short
clip and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]